man wait can I just say dude I'm happy
it's a was such a weird way to do it but
I'm happy we made a sketch dude I'm
really stoked about that oh yeah now I
it was really refreshing watching that
video I don't know it felt it's alright
yeah [ __ ] it's good it's good just just
pause it's way better to do that just
you know just don't say yeah I'm saying
yes make sure maybe it was right who's
really refreshing
no is great if relishing it was
refreshing you get go
yes or that magma I maybe it's a penalty
it's like when we say it we have to say
smegma right afterwards to like
humiliate ourselves [ __ ] said it
again [ __ ] whatever whatever whatever
I'm working on it you know no it was
good it was it was it felt like a return
to form yeah um and it made me go back
and watch our old sketches that we were
making on your channel mm-hmm and I
found a really funny comment on the
chick-fil-a one is still my favorite
really Wow
I really love that one I think it flows
really well I think it's like just well
acted it's like we've downplayed it
really well and it just comes off casual
and really funny to me what a crazy
thing for us to do what do you mean like
that see big bit fouled it again no we
weren't we didn't really have the green
light to shoot in there you know what I
mean yeah you were signed to full screen
as talent but I wasn't and it's just
Marcus and Gideon we just said yo we
just want to shoot something really
quickly and it is pretty that that's a
pretty big risk at your job to just pull
up with a camera in like a tripod and
that wasn't even the only time we did a
plenty of times yeah yeah we're shooting
every day yeah and cutting that was
funny too but you can hear the audio
Jones's
yeah so this is so if you guys haven't
seen the sketch search chick-fil-a board
meeting it's basically you know I won't
ruin it just watch it actually I have to
ruin it and to make this content or to
give context of the comment mm-hmm
basically we you know one of our intern
where the board members of chick-fil-a
we're like figuring out how to increase
profits and one of our interns says well
you can just stay open on Sundays and
then we fire them and get mad at them
basically that's the gist it's funnier
when you watch it one of the comments
that someone left two months ago is this
is terribly inaccurate
not only is CFA doing really well
financially but yet using the stock
ticker say but ideas like open on
Sundays and sell beef are horrible
because they're fundamentally changing
the identity of the restaurant you don't
bring in new business by changing what
your existing customer base likes about
you also I heard they tried spicy
nuggets but they didn't sell well enough
to make it a sustainable product I've
been to stores where they sell spicy
strips though the worst part is this
skit wasn't even funny well alright
fresh from his first business school
class Jesus Christ that's hot that's
high karma from Wall Street bets right
there my man weight frayed stock dude
anyway what are you gonna say where we
on Wall Street bets or something yeah
yeah yeah well get the end saying okay
yeah definitely what I was thinking yeah
no I'm I'm happy because I wanted to do
it after we got back from tour and I've
been thinking about it for a while it
was a weird way to pull it off
you know just not really seeing anyone I
have to say the way that came about was
house party reached out and they say hey
we'd like to sponsor a video something
like that and I said what the [ __ ] could
I do because I really didn't have any
ideas and then I had old sketch footage
specifically that men doing chores bit
yeah I had that footage already I had
that I shot that last year actually
because I do
this idea and then the Mormon sketch I
had already shot but the audio I forgot
what I did with it I lost it so the
footage I was gonna try an ADR it but
obviously that wasn't going to work so
at the last three days have just been
crazy
I felt honestly like I was producing a
music video or something because it was
just so wild Noah has been sad to know
him and he was cutting I think like you
know 12 hours a day yeah he just could
send me revisions I just you know kick
back with notes and it was to the point
that I was cutting with him so I don't
know I'm just really happy we got it out
so no it was great I love the format on
it yeah of it you know seriously like
having the fake commercial and the short
little sketches stitched together like
it felt like a real show like that's why
I think funnies you're saying like god
dammit that's why guys I feel something
like like that is very pitch a ball yeah
like if we even if we just inject a
little music in there like skits or
sketches with with music in them you
know yeah yeah that we could do yeah for
sure
it's crazy how writing a three-minute
song or a two-minute song come see yeah
there's so much easier than writing a
three-minute sketch I was thinking about
that after rendering the footage I was
thinking a three-minute song now feels
long which is why yeah but if you
compare that to three-minute sketch and
all I was thinking about was
entertainment falling in like what's you
know considered short form a
three-minute sketch if it's done not
like well it feels really long a
three-minute you can feel like five
seven minutes it can feel really bad
yeah but it's wild how it to it's a
two-minute song I don't know it feels
appropriate so that's why I cut every
bit down till up to about two minutes
because I feel that's the sweet spot for
almost anything right now mm-hmm
so that was no it felt really good it
felt like it breathe like I moved really
quickly and the pacing was really nice
and I feel that's honestly what kills a
lot of SNL bits is they just go way too
long
yeah and and when you think about it I
feel sketch premises you you murk them
in the first minute and the best you can
do are a few more tags that like
elevated key & peele [ __ ] is so
entertaining because it's such a high
production value but if you don't have
that then there's really no point to
keep watching alright but also like they
they don't really beat the joke to death
they usually just escalate to the point
where it's a different thing entirely
mmhmm mmhmm yeah
right is that fair to say Oh totally and
key is such a [ __ ] master at improv
so yeah well you know it's it's hard to
it's hard to beat that formula and peels
just solid with writing and and that
stuff but yeah I mean I say all this to
say I I hope when the [ __ ] quarantine
is over I hope this video does well
because I I'd want to just keep doing
stuff like this yeah you know
you